For any problem your work on this,
a moment where the sort of maybe it's
some model that no one else cares about
where it's sort of all fit together and
I found some simple way of doing
something.
There's also the models that people have
heard about,
some such as the models about extra
dimensions,
something else that we did having to do
with a different way of communicating.
Supersymmetry breaking.
There were a lot of fuel rica moments in
that making it work out.
Um,
and the fact that we could all tied
together.
So it's hard for me to pull this out
because a lot of the time when you're
working on something that's that one
thing that you get excited about.
I think one thing that surprised us a
ramen and I when we were working
together was the existence of the
possibility of the existence of an
infinite extra dimension.
Um,
you know,
people had actually thought there were
theorems that you couldn't have an
infant extra dimension that gravity
would just look wrong.
That there was no consistent way to do
it.
And it was really interesting because we
came across this by working really
following the consequence of our
equations to the end and there was just
no mistaking that it was allowing the
possibility of if an extra dimension.
And it was interesting to go back and
see what assumptions have been made that
made us think or make other people think
that it wasn't possible.
And just to see how the theory was
almost smarter than we were in and
worked it out.
So that was kind of fun.